the Joe Rogan experience did you ever
see any of Steven Seagal when he was
very young
mm-hmm when he was teaching in Japan I
was totally fast I mean it's like it's
really it's weird like me right like
like like serious actor thoughtful actor
I'm like what did you you know but I
like above the law yeah because I was
into all that stuff when above the law
came out and there was the scene in
above the law he's in an Aikido you know
ghee with the black thing and he's doing
this things and I was ripped I was like
oh my god like like this is so cool like
when have you ever seen this in a movie
yeah and and he was a you know big guy
and he made it violent yeah it's very
unusual sort of contribution to martial
arts because men martial arts movies
yeah he made it realistic yeah it was
one of the most realistic martial arts
movies ever yeah it was and you know
when you look back on it there's things
about it don't date yeah of course
but it was undeniably like really what
you just thing the thing of the guy
coming it's that simple thing that
thrust and the break and the thing it's
yes he also in the film when the guys
come at him in I see this is shows you
how it burns your brain there's a scene
where there's in a like a bodega and the
guy I think he smashes a bottle and he
comes at him and he does like a move and
Aikido it's called like code Takashi
it's like he it's like the wrist you
know it's like the wrist break flip over
and it was just like oh my god like he's
doing he's doing like you know nuanced
Aikido moves in a big action movie it
was kind of cool well he was one of the
first I think the first Westerner to run
a dojo in Japan I mean he was a
legitimate Aikido master yeah and I
think but what's interesting is when I
studied over there he was it's conscious
it was slightly controversial because I
don't think he was he had broken away
from like like ueshiba
mm-hmm Aikido he was doing he was doing
like the way that Gracie jiu-jitsu is
not pure Japanese jiu-jitsu he was doing
something with this it was somehow it
was associated more with Osaka than
Tokyo where the hombu dojo and Aikido is
and I there was some controversy
was just you know like the way things
are with schools of thought mmm
but um but yeah he had a certain legit
kind of thing and it's really wild
because people like Mike Ovitz who was
like the power agent of all of Hollywood
in the 80s you know Mike got a black
belt training with Seagal like he was
really serious Aikido issed
I didn't know that yeah that makes sense
yeah it does
he's a cautionary tale to them I mean
not even Novus I mean Seagal you know
yeah when I come I guess I honestly my
my I don't know anything about him past
a certain point like I I I don't know
what went on there yeah but I leave it
at that yeah I I don't
[Applause]